تدور طائرات الهليكوبتر طوال اليوم حول
مدينة المذبح الألمانية ذات المناظر الخلابة التي كانت
تقع في منحنيات نهرنا
والتي
تختنق الآن بالطين والحطام المقطوع عن
البلدات المجاورة
دون اتصال ،
وهذا هو موطن ديبرا الممتد ولكن
عائلتها في المملكة المتحدة ليس لديها أي فكرة عما إذا كانت لديها
نجت حتى رأوها على شاشة التلفزيون ،
وهي الآن تقدم فناجين
قهوة طازجة للحفاظ على الروح المعنوية ، لقد جئت عبر
الجبل إلى الأسفل هنا ثم رأيت للتو
يا إلهي الذي
لا يصدق ، كنا جميعًا نبكي
الجميع ، لقد
كان أمرًا فظيعًا حقًا
والجميع  السير نحوك ،
هذه بلدتنا الصغيرة
، لقد اختفت ، لقد ذهب السكان للتو ،
حاولوا توضيح ما يمكنهم
عمله مع رجال الإطفاء والشرطة والجنود ،
لكن كلما اقتربنا من
النهر ، زاد الدمار الذي لحق بجدار فندق
، العلامة التاريخية
لمستوى المياه في  آخر فيضان كبير في عام 1910
والذي تضاءل الآن بسبب هذه
الكارثة لإعطائك إحساسًا بالحجم ، فأنا
أقف على ضفاف النهر في
هذا الفندق.  بجانبه كان به ماء
طوال الطريق حتى الطابق الثالث ، يمكنك في
الواقع رؤية
خط المياه هناك ، مما يشير إلى
مدى ارتفاع مياه الفيضانات التي
لم يكن فيها فيضانًا عاديًا ، حيث تخلصت المياه من
أجزاء من الطريق تجتاح
المقبرة المحلية
على الأقل  تم نقل أحد المنازل بعيدًا من قبل
الجيران الفيضانيين أخبرنا أن جثة الشخص
الذي عاش هناك تم العثور عليها لاحقًا
في مزرعة عنب على جانب التل تعد استعادة
البنية التحتية الحيوية
أولوية قصوى للحصول على المساعدة التي تحتاجها المدينة ،
ونحن نحاول جعل هذا الطريق سالكًا
مرة أخرى  يشرح الرقيب الأول
هناك ، لا يمكنك رؤيته من هنا ،
يوجد جسر للسكك الحديدية
غير صالح للاستخدام تمامًا ، وهناك أيضًا الكثير من الأضرار على هذا الجانب ،
لكننا نأخذ
بعض المواد هنا
لتثبيت هذا الجسر
وتسهيل الحركة  من المعدات الثقيلة
التي شرحها ،
ولكن لن
نرى الحجم الهائل لمهمتهم حتى نلتف حول المنعطف ،
فهنا هنا معبر للسكك الحديدية وهذا
ما يفسر ما نراه الآن  تضخم النهر هنا
بسرعة كبيرة لدرجة أنه كان قادرًا على
الانقلاب على الجسر الذي يحمل
خط السكة الحديد ، يمكنك رؤية جميع
الأشجار والحطام الذي جمعه من
أعلى النهر ،
فقد أصبح هذا الجدار من الماء
يسقط
كل شيء فيه  المسار ، هذا مشهد
من الدمار الذي لا يُصدق
، لم تشهد هذه المدينة أبدًا أي شيء كهذا
لأجيال ، عاشت هذه المدينة بعيدًا
عن النهر
وكل ما يجلبه ، ولكن الآن مع حلول
الطقس القاسي في هذا الوادي الهادئ
، انقلبت المياه ضدهم